where they can find a space they huddle
in family groups
every day more and more people are
arriving here carrying whatever
possessions they could gather together
before fleeing the fighting that is
raging across afghanistan
as far as turning into a major
humanitarian crisis the numbers of
displaced people grow by the day even
the hour
the lightning offensive of the taliban
on cities in the north south east and
west of the country is simply
overwhelming afghanistan's army and its
government
farida kurasani's husband and brother
both police officers were killed by the
taliban in kunduz
they were attacked in their police
station
she escaped to kabul with her two
children
she has nothing now
she feels failed by everyone do you
think the americans leaving has caused
this problem
a day ago
joining 1800 families in this park
in afghanistan that's over twelve and a
half thousand people just in this park
it's already miserable it'll definitely
get worse
these families have escaped the fighting
for now but they are not safe
the taliban are creeping closer and
closer to the capital the real
impression you get here is that people
feel that kabul is being surrounded or
it's certainly going to be in the coming
weeks and of course the situation is
going to get worse food prices are
already going up petrol prices have gone
up as well and there'll be more
displaced people arriving here
and there seems nothing at this stage
obvious at least that's going to see the
taliban stopped in their tracks
on the face of it kabul seems pretty
much as normal
the traffic clogged up because huge
sections of the city are closed and
barricaded from potential suicide
attacks
20 years and trillions of dollars spent
attempting to defeat the taliban and
build a democracy here appears to have
been a mission on the verge of total
abject failure
stuart ramsey sky news cover